bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors d'abord de avant
de vous demander depuis combien de temps
vous êtes bloqué la situation en
australie est ce qu'elle est vous
inquiète
oui elle m'inquiète enfin on nous on
avait décidé de rester ici et donc on
était en road trip et en fait on est
sorti du désert on a eu de nouveau du
réseau et on a vu que ça prenait de
l'ampleur et que voilà on a décidé de se
mettre à l'abri dans une maison et sauf
que en vue de commencer évoluant
finalement on va rentrer et on s'est
compliqué d'expliquer nous et et voilà
on a réussi à avoir un billet un billet
d'avion la meilleure on sait pas si on
va pouvoir décoller donc les frontières
sont fermées
vous avez des informations sur les vols
internationaux qui est relié justement
l'australie au reste du monde pour
l'instant ou pas oui bah on suit ensuite
beaucoup les informations on est sur les
les groupes facebook des expatriés en
australie tous est donc oui tout le
monde se fait passer un peu les
informations et donc la seule compagnie
à c'est sûr on va dire c'est qatar c'est
la seule qui continue de décoller et
donc on voit là on a décidé de prendre
un billet d'avion avec eux pour un trio
avec les primes et les complications
il y a une obligation d'être confiné
dans le pays le confinement total des
buts mardi à minuit dans en est en tout
cas on est à une heure de perth donc
dans le western australia sinon ces voix
là c'est des conseils c'est les
distances de sécurité le masque le moins
se déplacer possible mais là pour
l'instant
sont toujours dehors quand j'imagine que
vous suivez un peu l'actualité vous êtes
vous avez les moyens de vous informer
sur cette pandémie qui touche l'europe
et d'autres continents aussi en
australie ce qu'on est inquiet là-bas
pour justement sur les moyens à
disposition pour faire face à cette
épidémie
oui les gens sont assez inquiets fins et
puis surtout au niveau des des
backpackers parce que voilà qui dit bob
parker dix voyageurs donc on est amené à
bouger tout le temps un pays à un autre
d'un état un note donc donc voilà
forcément on est un peu plus sujet à ce
genre deux ans fin à cette épidémie et
et oui au niveau après des moyens je ne
sais pas trop je sais qu'il n'ya pas
énormément de gain en australie et comme
si ces reculs et tout ça ils ont fait ce
qu'il fallait mais je suis pas trop dans
l'est au niveau des hôpitaux des jeux
serait pas trop il ya vous avez des
contacts avec l'ambassade de france en
imagine oui bah on les appelle là c'est
souvent dès qu'on a un doute sur quoi
que ce soit ou avant de prendre les
billets en prenant les billets ont je
pense qu'ils sont submergés d'appels
parce que c'est notre seul lien un peu
avec la france donc on les appelle là
c'est souvent pour se rassurer mais oui
serait assez disponible et je pense
qu'ils font ils essayent du moins de
serre ce qui peut donc vous les
ressortissants français dont vous faites
partie se sentent quand même soutenu par
les autorités françaises à distance
soutenu oui enfin du moins en or ont
réussi à avoir à peu près on a tout le
temps réussi à avoir le l'ambassade et
tout ça quand on les appelait appris bon
voilà au niveau du prix des billets
quand on nous a parlé des négociations
de prix des billets pour au niveau du
rapatriement s'est pas les prix en les
plans flambée quoi on nous demande de
rentrer mais c'est compliqué quoi ces
voyages en
les plonge dans bay vraiment donc là
vous êtes ont permis de vous êtes à
l'affût d'un vol justement à abordable
oui enfin un peu forcément on a pris 1
le premier parce qu'en fait on en a pas
de travail on n'a pas de logement à
partir de lundi donc on est obligé de
rentrer on a pris un billet là qui va
décoller samedi
donc voilà on n'a pas attendu le
rapatriement merci beaucoup
les décideurs d'avoir été en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france rappelle
que vous êtes donc une ressortissante
française bloqué actuellement en
australie bon courage à vous merci merci